I gave like you know my seminar last
year but it's great to come back in
person and get the actual like you know
Stanford Stanford experience I think the
Stanford experience started this morning
in my Uber to the to the university had
talks about Consciousness with the Uber
driver so I was really getting The Full
Experience there um so So the plan for
today is to tell you a little bit of
give you a little bit of an update about
the progress we made on uh special
perception for robotics pretty much
since my last seminar and I will start
with a slide just giving plenty of
credits to the uh students post talks
and collaborator doing the hard work and
the lifting behind the slides I'm going
to present
today so for those of you who don't know
my lab um I'm the director of the spark
club at MIT and we work we focus on
special perception and vision based
navigation we have a part particular
emphasis on uh motivating applications
which are safety critical high integrity
and highly
interactive so example of safety
critical applications are search and
rescue and maybe self-driving here if
the vision based system is failing maybe
you can fail to find survivors or maybe
you can crush your self driving cars we
care about applications which are high
integrity for example the rocket here on
the right hand side maybe there is no
human on board so it's not safety
critical but it's still a pretty
expensive piece of equipment you don't
want to break it and and we care about
applications that we call highly
interactive here we are interested in
all sorts of interactions interaction
within multiple robots interaction of
the robot with the environment or
interaction between robots and
humans so for today before getting into
our technical contributions I want to
start kind of a with a video a video
which is highlighting the type of
capabilities that we want to develop for
our robots it's not a real video it's
like you know computer animation but
it's a good summary of the capabilities
we want to develop so in the video what
you see is a drone which is able to do
very aggressive and uh uh natural like
you know navigation in complex
environments so the robots are doing in
this case some Vision based navigation
they're able to understand objects and
agents around them they're able to do
this clever interaction with objects and
they're even able to do interaction like
you know among each other okay so large
swarm of robots interacting in a very
natural way among each other so for
today I want to tell a little bit of the
work which you are doing towards this
kind of vision of robots with with this
kind of navigation capabilities and I'm
going to touch on three main topics
three main foundational topics we've
been working on which hopefully are
bringing us closer to this vision of uh
um these capable drones okay so today I
want to talk about robust estimation uh
as a first topic I want to talk about
hierarchical representations and then I
want to talk about self supervis
learning and I'm going to use this slide
a little bit as an outline of the rest
of the
presentation so so for the first two
parts robust estimation and hierarchical
representations I will focus a little
bit more on localization and mapping
problems or slam problems um for the
last part I will talk about object
understanding instead so self-supervised
object POS
estimation so let me start with the the
robust estimation
part and the point I want to make in
this part of the talk is that uh new and
old tools from robust estimation enable
unprecedented robustness in localization
and mapping problems and unlock
performance
guarantees um I told you about some of
the tools like you know last time I gave
the seminar in 2022 I will try to cover
a different set of algorithms and to
give a little bit of a summary of the
progress we made on these on these
topics over the last several years we've
been working on this for more than six
years
now so but let me start by telling you
why we care about robust estimation
robustness to what exactly so the
context is that we care about robustness
in the the context of localization and
mapping problem and in localization and
mapping problem typically the first
thing that you do or like you know key
element of simultaneous localization and
mapping systems is to reconstruct the
trajectory of your robot let's imagine
we deploy the robot in a completely
unknown environment the first thing that
we want to do is that the robot is
moving over time time one at time two is
covering a trajectory and want to
reconstruct how the trajectory looks
like okay I want to solve an estimation
problem to reconstruct the
trajectory what we are given in terms of
measur ments are relative measurements
betweenin different poses in the
trajectory for example we can measure
odometry which is telling how the robot
moved from time one to time two time two
to time three and so on and we typically
in Islam also have what are called Loop
closures which are measurements of uh
poses which are far away for example
these Dash lines will be Loop closures
the way you get this is typically
through Place recognition methods there
is a computer vision system that is
telling you look POS one and POS 7even
are observing the same piece of
environment the same part of the
environment so you can figure out what
is the relative relation between these
poses and from all the set of relations
which you can think being associated to
the edges in this graph you want to
reconstruct poses Associated to the
nodes of this
graph now the challenge here is that
many of these measurements will be
reasonable will be like you know noisy
but still fairly accurate the odometry
is going to be noisy and prone to drift
but will be relatively accurate the is
that for modern system that used for
Place recognition you will have a bunch
of outliers you will have a bunch of
measurements which are complete garbage
and it's pretty intuitive why that is
the case you might have two different
poses which are observing an environment
that looks kind of similar but this
there are two different environments
they just look similar but they are
different portion of the environment
this is something that is typically
called perceptual aling in robotics so
essentially some of the measurements
some of the loop closures are reasonable
some some of the others are completely
like you know wrong measurements are
complete
outliers why do we worry so much about
these outliers well um Let me show an
animation here so imagine that here I'm
solving some problem in which I want to
reconstruct the trajectory of the robot
which is this blue line if I have zero
outliers I get the reasonable
reconstruction of the
trajectory if I have five outliers over
thousands of
measurements the trajectory
reconstruction is very deformed already
if I have 20 outliers which is a tiny
portion tiny percentage of measurements
the entire trajectory is complete
garbage right we are not going to do any
navigation or any mapping for this type
of using this type of
trajectory so we studied how to get
robustness toout liers and of course you
can go back few years like you know
several years actually to the 60s and
people like you know will tell you from
robust statistics that uh to get
robustness to liers you have to use some
robust cost okay so imagine that you
have an optimization problem in which
you want to figure out the trajectory X
of the robot given a bunch of
measurements
why um robust statistics will tell you
that what you have to minimize a robust
loss function which will get you some
robustness to these bad
measurements the issue that people from
robust statistic didn't tell us out what
optimize actually this cost function and
it's provable we proved that uh um there
were results proven that is intractable
to try to solve this optimization
problem to optimality
and we also Pro that it's even hard
Computing an approximate solution to
this optimization problem so we spent a
really number of years trying to
understand how to solve better these
optimization problems and how to get
performance
guarantees so one of the algorithms we
propos is what is called grad
nonconvexity the real realization is
that the hardness of the optimization
problem is due to
non-convexity and insight behind grad
nonconvexity let me play this this again
is that instead of of solving directly
the original optimization problem maybe
we can start from a convex approximation
of the problem and iteration after
iteration we can increase a bit more the
amount of non-convexity until we recover
the original non-convex cost and at each
iteration we use the solution from the
previous iteration as initial guess from
the optimization with the result that
our set of solutions will track this wi
PA and eventually like you know get to
the optimal
solution so this algorithm um um
extremely robust to outliers for this
slam problem we get robustness
empirically to 70 90% of outliers that
you find in practice which is much much
better than having you know robustness
to 20 outliers as in this case so the
type of performance that you get in real
problems is that you try to figure out
the trajectory there are a bunch of
outliers which are these red lines grad
non convexity is able to solve this
optimization problem and figure out
which are the outliers and will result
in a much nicer um map
reconstruction if you paid attention to
my slide about the message of this part
I said all new and old tools from robust
estimation are going to be useful to
solve localization and mapping problems
and indeed for those of you are really
like you know maybe senior faculty
members working in computer vision you
realize that gradu non convexity is not
a new algorithm isan was proposed in the
'90s to solve a very different problem
like you know depth reconstruction in
images what we we did here is to disc
ReDiscover it and apply that to a
completely different setup which is post
estimation in the context of Slam
so um I want to show the impact of this
kind of algorithms across a number of
applications we've been using grad non
convexity for a number of problems in
this case I'm showcasing it uh for an
application of underground mapping in
the context of the DARPA Subterranean
challenge so we did this fun challenge
with the JPL and Caltech where the goal
was to deploy robots in very challenging
underground environments and having them
map the environments with very high
accuracy and through the use of grad non
convex in our slam system we are able to
um pretty much get uh post estimation
errors like you know localize the robot
with some meter Precision over very long
trajectories and again this is a case in
which is of course GPS denied is
underground but also like you know the
robot has no idea about the environment
so it's it's completely like you know
unknown environment
part of this allowed us to get um
competitive results in the DARPA
challenge we are second and first place
into out of the three uh competitions
the last competition didn't go as well
but you know that's another story we'll
do that over beers maybe um and Al all
the code you will see that as a pattern
I guess uh we tend to release as much
open source code as we can so if uh um
you want to try out like you know some
of these contributions you will find
them on
GitHub um with for we applied these
ideas in the context of self-driving and
in particular mapping for autonomous
valet parking so in this case you have
imagine you have a car with four cameras
around the car and you're trying to uh
map for example a parking lot so what
you see here is that the car is driving
around and we're are doing mapping of
the parking lot you will see maybe some
of the parking spaces here uh but you're
able to do this just with a bunch of
monop monocular cameras and very cheap
cameras as
well slightly more challenging then the
setup I show for the Subterranean
challenge just because now we have
monocular cameras and essentially the
loop closures are are going to be
measured up to scale so there is some
ambiguity in the Reconstruction but you
can still do an excellent job and reject
out liers through grad and non
convexity and just to tell you like you
know how much accuracy you can get
through these algorithms in the table
I'm showing again like you know the
error SYM meters compared to the length
of the
trajectory for like you know many many
data sets comparing the proposed
approach with the two stateof the art
slam systems Vince fusion and or Slam
3 and you can see also that we express
the drift which is the percentage the
error as a percentage of the trajectory
traveled so this LM systems first of all
can give you like you know very accurate
trajectories in which the
drift is a tiny fraction of the
trajectory traveled but also like you
know with these cool ideas from robust
estimation you can get just much better
accuracy over u b competitive great
systems such as vins fusion and uh and
um orb slam
Tre so uh from self thriving to space we
have been using some of these idea from
robust estimation also for terrain
relative navigation which is the problem
of estimating the pose of a rocket in
this case during the descend phase um I
will not mention too much about this is
a cool collaboration we did with drier
but the cool thing about this is that we
able to run some of our algorithms on
this two platforms so a high altitude
balloon and the blue AR new sheer rocket
so my students were pretty excited to
put algorithms on the payloads of of
these
Rockets um very challenging problem like
you know this platform navigating at
very high altitude uh very large speeds
with clouds and so on so very
challenging conditions and you can get a
decent localization error um through
robust estimation and so on which of
course is not going to be submers but
you know it's going to still be comp
able with the with U for example like
you know entry phase or terrain relative
navigation in this
case okay so I want to maybe conclude
this part just by summarizing I told you
about this grad non convexity idea but
the truth is that my group has been
working on this topic of robust
estimation for perception for a number
of years I want to do one slide summary
of the other contributions we did just
in case you are interested in this area
if you want to read more so the idea is
how to solve this kind of robust
estimation problems I was showcasing
applications to localization and mapping
but the truth is that this kind of
problems show up in post estimation for
objects using Point clouds images for
slam and so on so it's a very general
tool and what we did in our research is
to develop R like you know toolbox of
algorithms not a single algorithm but a
set of algorithms to solve these robust
estimation problems more reliably and
possibly with performance
guarantees so I told you about gr non
convexity the algorithm actually works
so well that is now included in Matlab
if you're curious about that in the
navigation toolbox in Matlab we have
graph theoretic approaches which are
able to prune out liers by reasoning our
compatibility between measurements and I
think last time I was giving the seminar
I was telling more about moment
relaxations which I think is one of the
coolest things that that we have done in
which the idea is to use um
semi-definite convex semi-definite
relaxations to get provably optimal Sol
solutions for this optimization problem
which is something that you know nobody
was was able to do before in
robotics so there is some reent progress
on that like you know also including
this idea of estimation contracts uh I
will not cover that too much today but I
want to stress that part of our work is
about designing certifiable algorithms
which carry some performance guarantees
in the sense that you know our
algorithms either compute an estimate
that can certifies the optimal estimate
or they can detect failure otherwise
okay so after this summary switch gear
and actually talk a little bit more
about hierarchical representations
instead and the point I want to make in
this part of the presentation is that U
highly interactive robotics applications
require metric semantic hierarchical map
representations in Real Time 3D scene
understanding algorithms to build
them so what I mean what do I mean by
interactive applications imagine that I
have interaction with humans I would for
my robot to understand and execute very
complex instructions for example I want
to tell my robot robot go GRA with a cup
of coffee on the table in the kitchen
what I'm arguing is that in order for
the for the robot to understand and
execute these instructions we'll need
metric semantic and hierarchical map
representations I don't think we'll need
too much convincing to do in convincing
that we need metric semantic Maps um of
course if the instruction is a robot go
grab me a cup of coffee on the desk the
robot will need to know about geometry
right we need to know how to get to the
desk how to avoid obstacles along the
way but we also need to know about
semantics which is what is the cup of
coffee what is the desk and how to
detect them in the
scene so a few years ago we developed a
library for metric semantic acting which
is called Kima um the high level picture
of what Kima does is Kim is taking a
bunch of camera images as well as
inertial data he's applying segmentation
semantic segmentation to the image and
then is mapping this 2D understanding of
the environment into a 3D map so you can
imagine that the robot is going around
and is building a 3D mesh of the
environment in real time this is a very
lightweight algorithm so everything is
running on CPU but not only can build a
3D map of the environment the map also
has different colors which correspond to
different semantic labels right so green
maybe are the chairs uh blue are the
desks yellow the cubicles so this is an
example of metric semantic map in which
the robot finally can understand the
identity and the semantics of different
objects in
3D well a bunch of extension work a lot
on these topics we have also have
extension like you know to multi robot
systems but after working on this we
quickly realize that metric semantic
mapping is actually not enough for the
type of interactions we're envisioning
with our
robots that's fairly easy to explain
imagine that I want to tell the robot
robot go search for survivors near the
fridge in the kitchen we realized that
in order for the robot to understand e
instruction the robot will need to
understand semantics Beyond objects for
example you need to understand rooms in
the environments instruction involves
the notion of kitchen but if you're just
mapping flat objects in the environment
the robot will have no idea about what
the kitchen is or where the kitchen is
and second this kind of instruction
require reasoning over relations within
elements in the environment for example
the struction says that the fridge is in
the kitchen so we have to understand
what that relation means okay we need a
map representation which is encoding
that
relation so over the past year we've
been working a lot on this new
representation uh which is called 3D
sying graphs in which you start modeling
semantics at different levels of
abstraction and you start thinking about
relation between objects uh what a s
graph is is just a hierarchical map
representation in which at the bottom
layer you have a 3D metric semantic mesh
pretty much the same that I had in
previous slides but as you go up in the
hierarchy you are obstructing away the
mesh into objects places rooms and
buildings I guess rooms buildings are
you know fly intuitive places are just a
representation topological
representation of the free space so you
can imagine that as a graph of free
space that represent traversability
between different places in the
environment so actually we're among the
first to propose this representation I
think the first work proposing this
representation is from iror Mani who is
a faculty here in civil engineering so
very cool work um what is end up ended
up doing like you know over the last uh
year is to be either little bit more
rigorous about why a hierarchical
representation is
needed and in this slide I'm comparing
essentially a flat representation in
which you just have boxels and maybe
you're attaching a bunch of semantic
labels to boxels against the type of
hierarchical map representations we are
proposing and we realize that uh first
of all hierarchical representations
scale better like a trivial point I
would say if you have to store a bunch
of attributes to each voxel the
scalability of this map will increase
with the number of semantic labels and
with the number of voxels If instead you
arrange things as a tree you can
essentially group Concepts together and
the scalability in terms of storage and
memory will get much much better over
time which is great simple like you know
simple
observation the second observation is
that if you care about modeling
relations modeling relation is pretty
easy if you have a graph based
representation you can just capture
relations as ages in the graph for
example you can model that the stove is
close to the fridge or maybe the kitchen
is connected to the dining room but
something that we proved which is a
little bit more fundamental is that uh
this type of what we call hierarchical
graphs have low trid so the trid is a
fundamental property of a graph and
proving that a graph has low treid is
pretty much allowing to conclude that
this easy is fast to do inference over
that over this graph okay so is much
nicer to have graphs with low three WID
and in a few slides like you know this
notion of three WID will allow us to get
some approximation result that you're
going to see applied to even graph
neural
networks okay so not only we prove that
this representation is much nicer in
terms of scalability treid and so on but
you also design the first algorithms to
build this type of 3DC graph
representation in real time uh using
sorda Hydra is a name of the system
which is putting these things together
and is allowing 3D singra construction
so imagine that our robot is starting in
a kitchen without prior knowledge about
the environment what these systems are
doing is to allow the robot to estimate
its own trajectory pretty much like you
know the same trajectory estimation
problem I was covering before he's able
for the robot is's allowing the robot to
understand objects and the semantics of
objects nearby syn uh fridge and so on
and then from
these semantics of objects drawing
conclusion about what are the different
rooms in the environment kitchen bedroom
and so
on so I will not tell you too many
details about this but you can imagine
that this actually to me is kind of the
evolution of the traditional slam
problem okay there is some slam problem
in solving for the mesh reconstruction
at the bottom layer so there is some
Metric semantic reconstruction but then
to get to this 3D s graph you have to do
much more first of all you have to do
more geometric reasoning for example you
have to extract the free space which is
this layer of places in the sing graph
and you do that by doing what is called
a generalized vorono
diagram the second thing that you have
to do is to Cluster the places into
different rooms and here we use tools
actually from uh from topology there is
a tool which is called persistent hology
which given a graph of places in our
case we break down the graph into
different rooms and then to reason over
the semantic of the different rooms
you're going to see in a while that we
use tools from geometric deep learning
and and in particular graph neural
networks I will I will cover that um in
detail like you a little bit more
details in a couple of
slides the exciting thing about this
work is that this is not just really a
robotics work like we can run and we pay
attention to being able to run these
algorithms on real robots right now so
we're doing all sorts of demonstration
with this I'm I'm going to show you you
know just a quick demo with a robot
mapping like you know building at MIT
but the bottom line is that we can run
these on on board computers for assemble
the Xavier an X and constructing the
different layers of a s graph in a
matter of milliseconds we can do all
these in real time on a real
robot so last time I was telling you a
little bit more details about uh maybe
how to um form the lower layers of this
representation for today I want to cover
a single topic which is how to attach
semantic labels to the top
layers so let's say that I'm building a
sying graph as the robot moves through
the environment I'm able to Cluster the
environment into different rooms in this
case R1 to R16 I guess how do I touch
labels to this room how do I know if a
room is a kitchen versus a bedroom so I
would like to tackle that problem and
tell you a little bit the tools that we
develop to tackle that
problem first of all I want to tackle uh
the elephant in the room
here just checking like you know maybe
this is an easy problem maybe the
progress we made in Vision language uh
models kind of like you know maybe it's
easy to classify and to understand the
environment and the different rooms in
the environment it's easy maybe I just
have to take a snapshot of my
reconstruction and I have to pass it to
a vision language model and query what
are the rooms in the environment maybe
it's that easy so I tried that um I took
the interface for lava I uploaded one of
the 3D constructions we have like you
know this is a point
Cloud um I can ask lava to describe the
point
Cloud kind of makes sense I will not
read this into to like you know to too
many details then I start having a
little bit more targeted
questions the question ask is how many
bedrooms do you see in the image right
we're interested in room classification
how many bedrooms do you see and the
language model is replying there is one
bedroom visible in the image located in
the open concept living space uh well
you start at the image you say okay I
count at least like you know one two
maybe three beds and bedrooms so this
doesn't sound quite right but maybe like
you know the language model is just
not paying enough attention maybe to the
image so let me try to help a little bit
see I can count three beds okay and the
language model reply apologize for the
confusion upon further um examination
there are inde three beds so then I ask
again like you know so how many bedrooms
do you see uh says okay finally there
are three bedroom bedrooms so like you
know maybe just didn't pay enough
attention in the previous stage but then
I keep going and I say upon further
expection I can count two beds and then
it starts agreeing with me that there
are two beds instead so I can still
essentially the language model to tell
me whatever I want here doesn't seem
like you know that there is enough
really understanding of the image but I
I say maybe I'm trying with problem
which is too hard maybe the
Reconstruction is noisy is like you
incomplete maybe I have to pass like you
know a top view of the environment I
make I make it into a floor plan uh with
room labels I mean that's that should be
easy um we start a new conversation um
how many bedrooms do you see in this
picture uh one two uh three and four and
then says the instead so yeah I think
you know you can prompt your way to get
in the the exact answer but uh uh that
is not the point what I'm arguing is
that it's not as easy like you know the
language model will not have an
immediate understanding even in a very
simple problem will not have an
immediate understanding of uh of rooms
in the
environment so therefore we have to come
up with tools which are a little bit
more clever and today I'm going to tell
you like you know a couple of slides
maybe the tools set we
developed again the problem is that you
have U this s graph and you want to come
up with semantic labels for the
different rooms semantic labels being
like you know kitchen bedroom and so on
and um we do this as humans all the time
the way I think we do that as humans is
that we look at the objects around us
and from the objects we can really
understand easily understand what is the
room type we are we are traversing so
for example if in a room there is there
is a bed there is a chair there is a
book we can conclude that that's a
bedroom right so we would like to do the
same type of inference with with our
robots the old style version of the this
type of inference would be something
like you a probabilistic graphical model
for that we need to arode a lot of
information the modern version of that
is is a graph neural network how many of
you are familiar with graph neural
networks
here maybe Al so in a graph neural
network you have a graph in nodes
imagine that you know five is the room
node and these other four are object
nodes what you do is you do some message
passing to form embeddings at each node
and then you classify these embeddings
into I don't know bedroom bathroom and
so on um so it's just neural message
passing over a graph we use this indeed
as a baseline but you actually propose
something that is a little bit more
clever is a new graph neural network
which is something that we call the
neural
tree and I'm going to present this idea
in a single picture just because it's
really that simple like you know I can
present this IDE in in in a single
figure so the idea of the neural three
is that you do not have what we say is
that we do not have to do message
passing over the original graph what you
have to do is to transform the graph
into a tree using something that is
called a three de composition and then
you have to do message passing on the
three instead and if you do this trick
you just gain like know performance
guarantees and you get much better
performance in practice
okay so for the few of you might be very
familiar with probabilistic graphical
models you might have seen the junction
three algorithm what we are doing is
essentially like you know a neural
version of a junction three algorithm so
we bridging insights from graphical
models and uh and graph neural networks
together to get performance
guarantees so what do we gain but do in
this neural three architecture first of
all we gain theoretical uh guarantees
there is a long statement like you as a
theorem I will just summarize what are
the main points imagine that f is a
probability distribution over the graph
that you care
about and let's call G the set of
functions that can be um implemented to
your graph neural net to your neural
three architecture what we prove is that
uh there is you can find a g which is
close enough to any probability
distribution up to an error Epsilon and
you can do this using a number of
parameters which you can imagine as the
weights your neural network which is
this capital n and the number of
parameters grows linearly in the size of
the graph which is good like you know
linearly is good and only grows
exponentially in the three width of the
graph okay but we just prove that s
graphs as small three WID right so
essentially what I'm saying is that with
this result about the three WID we can
prove that these architectures are
provably expressive over sing graphs
with a small number of parameters okay
so in a nutshell again let me repeat
this the neural three will need a
parameter which is exponential in the
three WID but the three WID will be
small for sing
graphs okay so um maybe we don't care
about the theory want to see how this
works in practice so we do um
experiments in this casee on the
Stanford 3D Syra data set in which there
are this pairs of objects and rooms and
uh we evaluate the percentage of things
which we classify correctly of course we
would like for this to be 100% like you
know these percentages are what we show
uh in the in the table higher the better
and in the table we compare different
types of message passing graph attention
like you know another types types of
message passing We compare doing message
passing on the original graph which is
standard graph neural networks against
the neural three architecture which is
what we
propose and you can see that just by
doing this trick of the 3D composition
we boost the performance by you know 10%
in many cases substantial boosting
performance with really a minor addition
in the pipeline and by the way because
our graphs have small three wids it
means that the three de composition is
not huge which means that the the
runtime of these algorithms of
traditional graph neural networks and
neural three are not very different so
we don't lose much in terms of in terms
of
computation okay so
um I want to stress now for a couple of
slides just some very recent extension
of this uh uh 3D singra work this is s
that will will be an archive hopefully
today is something that you know we are
pretty much finalizing right now which
is the observation that hierarchal
representations are not just for indoor
environments but it makes sense to
Define hierarchical representations in
arbitrary environments okay so imagine
now we have an outdoor environment we
can still reason over the mesh of the
environment we can reason over objects
places which represent traversability
but then instead of classifying things
into rooms buildings and so on we can
classify them into maybe Field Road Park
and so there is still a hierarchy that
we can leverage in
Outdoors so the question we asked is can
we adapt our adapt our algorithms to to
reason over arbitrary possibly outdoor
environments and the way we're thinking
about this problem is uh is a problem of
classifying places into high Lev regions
so I want to take this graph of nodes
which are the black nodes and I want to
classify if a place is part of a field
it's part of a road and so on leveraging
probably sem possibly semantic
information from the lower layers which
is for example which objects are nearby
for each
place so in theory I could solve this
with the neural tree I can solve this
with the graph neural network but there
are two challenges in outdoor
environments the first challenge is that
I'm not really sure which Concepts to
include in the S graph right I do not
have rooms like you know I can have very
arbitrary set of of Concepts and I
really don't want to do the job that for
every testing scenario I have to come up
with a different set of objects I would
like to automate that process the more
fundamental problem is that there is a
lack of training data for uh for indoor
s graphs there are a bunch of like you
know training data sets for outdoor you
can think maybe there is Google Maps and
things like that but actually there are
no data sets which are connecting these
high Lev concepts with the objects in
the data set okay it's not easy to do
training at
all so we try to solve this problem with
with a couple of contributions the first
one is to create a special ontology and
ontology is just a graph of Concepts and
relations so the idea is that we have to
Define an ontology which is summarizing
the set of Concepts we care about
dividing Concepts between high level
Concepts like you know this can be the
equivalent of rooms but can be fields
and things that apply to Outdoors and
lowlevel Concepts which are pretty much
the
objects and um we can also establish
relations which are saying for example a
bed is more likely to be in a bedroom a
kitchen is very likely to contain a
fridge The Twist that we have of course
ontology like you have very long history
The Twist that we have is that we have
we let the language model actually
populate a very dense ontology for us
the main problem in building onology is
that once you scale the number of
Concepts and the number of Ages is very
tough for a human to populate that we
just qu a language model with things
like uh which K elements from the lowest
layer are most distinctive about the
high level concept for example what are
the objects which are more distinctive
of a kitchen okay and with the response
of a language model we populate all the
edges in the in the
ontology um the other thing that I think
is pretty cool is to use uh to try to
use the structure of the onology to help
learning in particular in a case in
which you do not have a lot of training
data
and to do that we use a tool which is
called logic tensor networks logic
tensor Network in a nutshell are tools
to enforce logical rules as part of the
training of a neural network so for
example in a neural network I want to
give uh my neural network a bunch of
training examples but then I want to
make sure that the prediction of my
neural network are consistent with the
ontology I want to make sure that the
neural network is not predicting that
the rock can be in the bedroom okay so I
want to enforce these kind of hard
logical constraints on top of my
training
data logic tensor networks will allow
just that and uh just to give you like
you a very like you know brief summary
what's going on logic t or networks will
use a loss function which is not the
typical like you know crossentropy and
so on but will be a cross function which
is quantifying satisfaction of a set of
formulas logical formulas these are the
five and of course if you think about
logical formulas typically you think
about kind of 01 satisfaction what logic
tensor network does uh is to use real
logic in which you relax satisfaction in
the interval 01 and you make everything
differentiable just by just relaxing
satisfaction in 01 okay so is a
differentiable logic that's one way like
you know you can take this the advantage
of this is that now we can use uh uh
partially some training data for uh
during training of our graph neural
network but we can also use the spatial
ontology to kind of support to provide a
supervision signal for for the neural
network
itself okay so um let me show a couple
of slides with results here um
qualitative results are on the right in
this case I'm starting with indoor
environments just because we have a lot
of uh data for testing in this case so
you see here the environment being split
in different rooms and like you old the
room labels and here I have uh the
quantitative results so the quantitative
quantitative results are showing the
accuracy of the classification of the uh
rooms in this case
for decreasing amount of training data
okay so here I have close to 100% I have
lot lots of data here I have like you
know very little training data what
happens is that if you have lots of
training data if you use for example uh
here cross entropy you have like you
know very good
performance and the proposed approach
which is based on this logic tensor
network will have pretty much similar
performance so when when you have plenty
of data you probably don't need this
logic tensor network but as the amount
of training data drops essentially the
cross entropy standard crossentropy
formulation will just drop and we'll get
to essentially random guessing of the
labels and instead the proposed approach
will approach a lower bound which is the
amount of information in the spatial
ontology okay so in other words if you
remove completely the the the training
data the proposed approach will still
know correlation within objects and
places through the spatial ontology
which will guarantee a minimum level of
performance okay so if you're here you
probably don't care about logic tensor
networks if you have very little data um
they can make a huge uh difference for
you so for different projects we try
these out in outdoor
environments the results are quite like
you know uh easy to understand already
from the figures what you see in the
figures are ground root labels which are
the the polygons here and the color of
the classification is the result of our
Network so essentially if all these dots
a green color with the bonding box it
means that we are classifying correctly
if he said they don't agree like in this
case for example the color doesn't agree
it means that the the classification is
incorrect and we see that we are able to
do like you know design classification
of like you know many different concepts
in large scale outdoor data sets
involving like you know roads buildings
forests and so on this is an experiment
with the Army research lab at West Point
as well as like you know dealing with
completely different environments like
you know this is a beach like Seaside
environment close to close to Boston and
I will not spend too much time about
that but it turns out that with these
logic tensor networks you can even
predict at test time Concepts that you
haven't seen at training time just
because the ontology can incode
relations that maybe you haven't seen at
test time we can do even prediction like
you know kind of zero shot prediction of
objects of regions that we haven't seen
at test
time also in this case we really care
about running these on real robots so
I'm showing just an exp experiment of a
real robot running in the courtyard near
to our building at Mit the robot of
course is building like you know this
map semantic map of uh of the scene is
isolating different objects for example
chairs versus boxes and so
on and if you see uh maybe let me
restart this if you see on top of like
you know building these lowlevel
Concepts uh the logic tensor network
will allow to segment the space into
different regions so for example we find
that there is a walkway there is some
out off-road terrain and we're going to
see this a little bit better in in a few
seconds okay so that's the type of
performance that we get again like you
know the real image here and the real
time reconstruction on this side like
there's a little bit of an acceleration
just to to be
fair the robot is not moving that fast
and you see that uh the logic tensor
network is getting from objects to
classifying
um should really cut this video in a
better way but let's see if I
can so in this case these top ones are
the places and they're classified into
different semantic regions and I think
it shows a little bit better later in
the video but I think you got you got
the point
there so to close this part I was
insisting a lot on this idea of
hierarchical maps for for robotics now
that we have these Maps or like you know
we made good progress on these Maps what
can we do with them and in this slide
I'm summarizing that there is a lot
actually we can do with them um we have
been showing even in the original paper
that we propos about s graphs that you
can do now hierarchical P planning you
can speed up motion planning a lot on
these maps you can do you can apply
reinforcement learning you can do object
search with much better performance
compared to pixel to action approaches
and you can even use the SC graph to
reduce the amount of communication in
multi-root systems the thing that was
reassuring is that the work at the
bottom is from actually different groups
that also found sing graphs to be very
useful in particular for problems
involving task or task em motion
planning as well as go navigation and
then me show improve per improve
performance when using these
hierarchical
models and there is a lot more to be
done like in terms of human robot
interaction monitoring prediction and so
on but uh this model seems to be pretty
useful for for
robotics so I want to spend the last
five minutes or so here U talking about
self-supervised learning I will make
this like you know quite quite fast um
the basic observation here is that for
safety critical robotics application we
need algorithms perception algorithms
they're able to distinguish correct
estimates from incorrect ones and we
want them to adapt in a self-supervised
fashion uh why do I care about failures
and adaptation well even if you take the
latest Foundation model and so on there
are always going to be errors in
particular in scenarios which are not
the typical ones that you encounter in
uh in the training data
if you don't believe that uh I just took
like you know a random image from the
web like you know of course is like a
robot in kind of fire uh scenario um and
I pass this to a Transformer based
semantic segmentation architecture one
former like you know is a pretty good
reasonable Baseline is a very recent
approach and you see that even this
state of the art Transformer based
method will classify the robot as a far
hydrant and the fire as a light so
definitely you know we have to worry
about failures even if we go for large
Foundation models
so we started thinking about about
essentially selfup supervision for
object understanding uh and in
particular for object POS estimation so
it's a little bit more geometric than
this example uh so let me set the stage
a little
bit so um in the first part of the talk
I discussed a lot about robust
estimation right I said that robust
estimation can be applied to
localization and mapping problem in this
part of the talk I'm going to apply that
to a posst estimation problem for
objects in which I say that pass to the
robust estimation a bunch of
measurements of points on the object I
care about and I want the robust
estimator to figure out what is the pose
of the object I care
about what is the role of learning in
all that uh the role of learning is that
typically these measurements like you
know these detections of the object are
produced by neural network right so what
I ask is that now that we have much
better robust estimation techniques can
I use them to
can we self superise a neural network
using certifiable estimation algorithms
what I'm going to argue is actually that
certification and self-supervision are
very coupled topics if you solve one
you're very likely to be able to solve
the other as well and I will show you
the Insight like you know I will keep it
high level but I will show you intuition
behind that just with a simple
animation so imagine that you have a
pre-train neural network okay a neural
network which is train maybe just in
simulation this can be maybe a
foundation model like you know pre-train
model and imagine now that I'm going to
expose that to real data which is
unlabeled okay so imagine at test time I
provide a batch of three samples to my
pre-train neural
network um so what happens is that I can
just do a forward pass of the neural
network the neural network will predict
a bunch of key points and then I can do
my like you know robust estimation
algorithms to predict a pose of the
object now if you have a certifiable
algorithm which is an algorithm that is
able to distinguish correct estimates
from incorrect ones I'm able to
understand which of the results is
correct and which of the results is
wrong and I can do something very simple
I can take the correct one as a Pudo
label and back propagate the result to
improve my neural network a little bit
and then I can try with another batch of
data the network now improved a little
bit and maybe in this case I produce two
correct results and I can back propagate
this a bit and then I can keep going
like you know incrementally improving
the quality of my neural n Network again
without without any labels essentially
the pipeline by certifying which outputs
are correct will create labels on the
Fly okay seeo labels on the
Fly okay so we applied this idea for
object posst estimation we are giving
rgbd uh data we have to estimate the
pose of an object in the image again
there is a neural network that we want
to kind of self supervise and improve
over time we have this robust corrector
which is our robust estimation module
and we have certific tickes which are in
charge of deciding if we got the right
estimate or the wrong
one and the type of performance we get
is summarized by this video so we start
at initial iteration in which the
pre-train network is not doing great so
you see that the the prediction of the
object doesn't match the point Cloud
very well but the more set supervised
iterations we do the better like you
know the point cloud in green is
aligning to the object which means the
better job we are doing at estimating
the pose of the object and all of this
is just improving the performance of the
network without the need for any
supervision from a human so uh we push
this this is more recent line of work
like you know we push this in a couple
of papers at RSS we actually shown that
we can apply this idea also if you put
multiple models in parallel so if you
have an ensemble of model you can kind
of self supervise them at the same time
and you can take advantage that maybe
one model is cross supervising the other
and so on so you can apply these idea to
an ensemble of models
instead um I will spend Maybe one slide
about results and then I know we'll have
to stop but um um you can look at the
performance of uh maybe like you know
this video like you know uh this figure
the this is the cumulative distribution
of the errors you want this to be on the
left as much as possible um the proposed
approach is in blue we actually do
pretty well compared to a fully
supervised Baseline and we do much much
better than self 6D Plus+ which is a
self-supervised
baseline um we have been applying this
idea for all sorts of problems Nas is
using this for lunar um Tower assembly
we're doing a project right now for
whereas Automation in which we do Post
estimation with these methods and we're
having fun also using these kind of post
estimation methods for uh aggressive IAL
manipulation as you can see in the video
on the right maybe let me get the real
real demo so we can do aggressive
manipulation of objects just by
detecting them uh in real
time so in summary today hopefully take
over like you know a lot of ground I um
you saw like you know some of the
progress we made on robust estimation
singra and hierarchy representation and
self-supervised learning and hopefully
that will bring us closer to having
agents that can interact with objects
and with the environment and the vision
based navigation so I wrap up here
thanking the sponsors and of course
thanking you for your attention
[Applause]
right